Five years ago thanos erased half
of the population of the universe
delayed the emergence
of the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
how long do we have seven days
Welcome back everyone thanos was right this is
gonna be my eternals video all about how thanos
saved the avengers and half the planet from the
celestial host there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs here in the brand new footage that they
released so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get everything later this week my eternals post
credit scene video as well as my full movie easter
eggs breakdown videos we'll start posting so if
you haven't seen the movie yet be sure to go see
it when you have the opportunity this video will
only contain things that i've talked about in my
previous eternals trailer videos so if you've seen
the trailers for the movie then this won't contain
any big spoilers that you don't already know about
but during this new marvel eternals trailer the
longer scene that they released in the beginning
of the movie when richard madden's ikaris and
salma hayak's ajak character are meeting again for
the first time in thousands of years just chatting
it up on the events of avengers endgame thanos the
snap and the blip ajak mentions that she's been
contacted by arishem the judge the prime celestial
he's the leader of the entire celestial host that
giant red one that you see in all the trailers
the members of the celestial's race that
band together in a team call themselves the
celestial host that's why we call ego the
living planet a rogue celestial because he
was a celestial just like them just as powerful
but he didn't become part of the celestial host
so in this conversation that they're having she's
telling ikaris that the celestials have seen that
the emergence has been jump started by the hulk's
infinity gauntlet snap during avengers end game
and as i've talked about in my previous videos
the emergence is the event that describes the
emergence of a totally new celestial that's been
growing inside planet earth for millions of years
feeding on the low-level cosmic energy given off
by humans is a very matrix-like explainer for the
marvel universe humans as batteries but make it
marvel i talk about how this is sort of connected
to one division and the way she manipulates
background cosmic radiation the energy given
off by the infinity stones but i don't want this
to turn into like a 20 or 30 minute video so ajak
and ikaris are aware that when the emergence is
going to happen it's going to destroy the entire
planet like look at how big arishem the judge
is orbiting the earth when he's communicating
with ajak on this celestial zoom call he's
massive he's like galactus size so even if
the new celestial winds up being smaller it bursts
out of the earth it would destroy it completely
and over the past 7,000 years that they've
been on earth the eternals have grown to
love humanity kind of like their own children
so they're freaking out about how to stop this
from happening but during this scene ajac is
basically telling ikaris it's about to go down
ineffectively it means that thanos saved the
earth the half of humanity that he didn't snap
like half is better than nothing right so thanos
saved the avengers from the celestials not just
the celestial growing inside the planet because
that would have destroyed them when it burst
out of the planet but thanos also saved the
avengers from airshem the judge and the rest of
the celestial host because all the celestials care
about is the emergence hatching this new celestial
creating more celestials all over the universe
doing similar emergence type plans on other
worlds they only care about humans and the other
lesser life forms around the universe in so much
as they're the cosmic food source that the new
celestials they're trying to create feed on this
will all sound familiar too when we get to thor
love and thunder and gore the godbutcher's plan
like you saw the thanos was right memes after
avengers infinity war and avengers end game
when we get to thor love and thunder you'll
see a lot of gore was right memes posting again
gore goes around killing the gods of the marvel
universe because he feels like they don't care
about humans or the other people that serve
them it's kind of the same situation with the
celestials it's like the loki explainer ants and
boots but if the celestials are attempting to grow
a new celestial on a planet and something happens
to kill it or doesn't go to plan the way they want
it the celestial host will show up and just wipe
the planet of all life and start over again on a
different planet we've actually already seen that
happen that's kind of what's going on during this
classic guardians of the galaxy scene with
east on the searcher using the power stone
when the collectors explain the history of the
universe the history of the infinity stones he
shows issan the searcher a member of the celestial
host using the infinity stone to wipe the planet
now given the new context on the celestial's true
plan this whole time since they were created it's
implied that whichever celestial they were
trying to grow on this particular planet
something happened to it and it went off the rails
so they just wiped the experiment and started over
again on another planet i know a lot of you are
also asking now is this what happened to thanos
home planet on titan because it also got destroyed
i'll talk about that later in the video too
but even though thanos is a legit psychopath
confirmed if you think about it he really did save
the avengers in the planet from the celestials for
at least a little while until the avengers time
heist and avengers end game the hulk's infinity
gauntlet snap brought everyone back the reason
why the blip jump started the emergence again is
because the celestial growing inside the planet
needs a certain amount of cosmic energy that
it leeches off the sum total of humanity before
thanos's infinity gauntlet snap there were little
over 7 billion humans on earth so had thanos not
snapped the infinity gauntlet the emergence would
have happened about seven days after the ending
of avengers infinity war like infinity war would
have ended with the same kind of downer ending
except the giant celestial would have burst out of
the planet shattering it and killing everyone on
earth so when he snaps the infinity gauntlet half
of the people on the planet vanished it chopped
the cosmic power supply line to this new celestial
that was growing delaying the emergence as ajak
says the way she talks about it she makes it sound
like the emergence would have taken a lot longer
like many years but not delaying it indefinitely
eventually it still would have happened it would
have just taken a lot longer but when the hulk
brought everyone back with the blip it sort of
reset the countdown timer back to what it used
to be before avengers infinity war with seven
days left the eternals movie jumps all over
the timeline like ancient history to explain
how the eternals were created but in present
day most of the eternals movie takes place
around the same time that spider-man far from
home is happening so the ending of the eternals
movie when they're trying to stop this emergence
is happening around the same time spider-man
is getting doxed by mysterio and j jonah
jameson in that spider-man post-credits scene
and now if you think about it ajak and ikaris seem
like they're kind of relieved on the dl that the
snap happened without celebrating the loss like
they're not complete psychopaths like thanos but
they didn't want to see all of humanity completely
destroyed the whole idea is that they're just good
soldiers in this celestial army marching to
the beat of the drum if all the relationships
aren't clear between the eternals ajak has been
the leader of their group since they were created
so she's known about this secret celestial plan
the whole time they kind of get that across in
the trailers that she's the only person at least
at the beginning of the movie who can communicate
with the celestials and they would have had to
let her know about this grand plan the emergence
so she's been deceiving the other eternals this
whole time even though she doesn't enjoy doing
it she genuinely does care about humans it's just
that she's still super old school literally and
metaphorically because they're so long-lived and
at least it's implied that up to this point in
history she hasn't been willing to defy the will
of ayrshin the judge i know there's all kinds of
side questions about why the celestials need to
grow more celestials if you're not familiar with
the full backstory on the celestials there's this
whole idea that the celestials have been fighting
a giant cosmic war since they were created with
other celestials so they need to replenish their
ranks like celestials have been killing other
celestials over time marvel's starting to do a
lot more space based more cosmic movies so we'll
probably get into that in future avengers movies
in what about thanos home planet of
titan was something similar happening
there with the emergence were the celestials
trying to orchestrate a similar plan growing a new
celestial on titan before it was destroyed but the
whole idea is that thanos was born to an eternal
family and if the celestials only send eternals to
planets where they're orchestrating emergence-like
plans then at least in the mcu wouldn't that have
been the case on titan that's why his parents
would have gone to the planet titan the way thanos
talks about it titan was destroyed less than 2 000
years ago and there's no mention of another
celestial being created during that time so i
think it's implied that celestials were trying
to grow another new celestial emergence style
on titan and something happened to that and the
celestials then showed up and basically destroyed
the entire planet just to wipe the experiment and
start over again somewhere else in another early
theory at some point thanos learned about the
emergence that it was going to happen and that's
what he was talking about when he said he tried
to warn his people and they shunned him because
he came up with his plan to stop the emergence by
erasing half of all life but he failed to stop it
his planet was destroyed and that set him on his
grand quest his master plan to balance life in the
universe to stop the celestial host that would
give thanos more of a john wick style arc like
he's still not a hero more of an anti-hero but
less evil than he comes across in the mcu so far
there's been talk about them doing more with the
thanos character other versions of thanos like
young thanos in future mcu projects this would
actually be a good way of setting up a young
thanos arc in future eternal sequels when they
start introducing the idea of the eternals from
other planets like there are eternals all over the
universe like these ones that the celestials just
put on planets when they're trying to grow new
celestials like they could do a young thanos arc
in the flashbacks of future movies or even just
a full-blown legit young thanos movie or a young
thanos disney plus series but because the eternals
movie is coming out tomorrow my full eternalist
post credit scene video will post thursday night
then my eternals full movie breakdown easter eggs
will probably post on friday make sure you enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss that and
be sure to go see the movie when you have a chance
everyone click here for my eternals black knight
kit harrington video to learn all about his
character and his future in the avengers movies
and click here for my new marvel morbius trailer
with easter eggs for every spider-man movie
ever thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!